hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und ich trete zu euch hin an diesem tage
weil mir etwas ganz ganz furchtbares
passiert ist worüber ich aus oder bist
du ich habe ein video von sarah defizite
gesehen was heißt digital wieso ich nie
wieder ein gucci store betrete und
dieses video war einfach nur aber darum
soll es heute gar nicht gehen also um
ihr video
doch kurz lasst uns kurz lassen uns kurz
darüber sprechen also das video war
absolut absoluter müll diese frau hat
mich auf so vielen ebenen einerseits wie
sie spricht und andererseits der inhalt
wie kann man so krasse first world
provinz haben oh mein gott und wie kann
man so viele fehler machen und dann
diese fehlersuche umdrehen als ob jemand
anderes einen fehler gemacht hat das war
aber ich weiß auch nicht warum ich
dieses video gesehen habe warum ich mir
das zum ende hin angeschaut haben
ballack so viel werbung rein und aber
jetzt ist mir letzte woche etwas
passiert wozu ihr gerne eine story time
sehen wollt also auf instagram haben wir
die leute geschrieben
mach doch mal bitte eine story time
erzählt doch mal bitte deine story aber
da ich noch nie ne story erzählt sich
nicht ganz genau wie man so eine story
erzählt ich erzähle ist einfach mal so
wie es euch sarah die idee erzählt hätte
mit ein bisschen mehr drama ein bisschen
mehr
also viel spaß beim einer story time im
style von sarah de gea
die idee sei ich war ja letzte woche in
köln bei kelly und mirella wir haben
videos gedreht und total die tolle zeit
gehabt und dann wollte ich am donnerstag
nach hause fahren die drei sind morgens
bei mirella um 7 uhr aufgewacht und
haben erst mal noch ein bisschen
gekuschelt weil das ist das was wir so
machen wenn wir aufstehen und dann bin
ich im neuen uba mirella los war nicht
um 9 48 hinzukriegen wollte und oh mein
gott das versuch krass ich bin runter in
die u bahn gegangen aber die wäre erst
ein paar minuten gefahren also musste
ich wieder hoch rennen und dann in ein
taxi steigen und es hat alles voll lang
gedauert also weißt du echt um so 9 uhr
45 erst beim zug und bin dann
eingestiegen naja und dann sind wir halt
um 9 48 aus köln losgefahren und gegen
12 uhr habe ich schon gemerkt dass
irgendwas nicht so ganz stimmt es wurde
draußen immer wenn die
man hat gemerkt da bahnt sich irgendwas
an und um 12.30 als wir mit dem nichts
waren bleibt plötzlich der zug stehen
und der schaffner sagt dass irgendwas
auf den gleisen liegt und ist ungefähr
noch eine halbe stunde dauert bis wir
wieder losfahren können und da waren wir
alle schon so genervt im zug wo ich
hasse es kennt ihr das wenn der zug hat
einfach so verspätung hat und ihr
einfach nach hause walt oder irgendwohin
weit und das ist ja auch schon so
genervt aber okay war ja noch nicht so
schlimm bayern eine halbe stunde und
dann nach einer halben stunde sagte
plötzlich ja es wird doch eine stunde
dauern und ich dachte mir schon so herr
ihr habt doch eine halbe stunde gesagt
weil halt irgendwas auf den gleisen
liegt sei die behindert könnt ihr nicht
dass appel ich weiß behindert sagt man
nicht seid ihr hängen geblieben ihr
müsst du einfach nur den ast wieder von
den gleisen nehmen was kann daran so
schwer sein
ich hatte echt nicht verstanden also
wirklich nicht und dann war es
mittlerweile 12 30 und sind immer noch
nicht los gefahren und dann hat er
gesagt ja es wird doch zwei stunden
dauern wie bitte
zwei stunden was soll ich denn zwei
stunden na gut ich konnte ein video
schneiden was ich eh schneiden musste
aber zwei stunden was soll ich denn zwei
stunden zum zug machen
das hat mich schon so aufgeregt er und
dann war's halt 14 uhr 30 und es gab
halt immer noch keine neuigkeiten was
jetzt los ist wenn wir weiter fahren wir
standen halt auch so mitten im nichts
genau um 14.30 sind wir dann weiter
gefahren in einen bahnhof wünsdorf das
ist kurz vor hannover und da ist einfach
nichts da ist kein gucci store
da ist nicht mal ein h & m gibt da also
einfach nur gleisen und sonst nichts
sondern was hat auch schon 14.30 und ich
habe an dem tag hat noch nicht gegessen
weil ich ja dachte dass ich um 14 uhr
schon wieder in berlin sein werde und da
einfach essen kann und das hat mich
schon wieder so aufgeregt weil ich mir
einfach irgendwas zu essen hätte
mitnehmen können wenn mir jemand gesagt
hätte dass das halt alles so lange
dauert aber ich wusste dass ja nicht so
gut klavier war angekündigt ich habe das
aber nicht mitbekommen weil sorry auf
twitter habe ich nichts von xavier
gelesen und auf instagram hat auch
niemand was gepostet also woher sollte
ich das wissen das sind sturm kommt ich
hatte zwar ein flex ticket und konnte
fahren wann ich möchte aber da hätte mir
vorher jemand sagen können bevor ich in
den zug einsteigen
heute kommt ein sturm hat aber keiner
gemacht voll packe ich meine behindert
ich meine verhaltensgestört
hängengeblieben sorry ich weiß ich sage
so oft behindert das ist ja und dann
kommt dieser spaßt von lokführer ich
meine macken und sagt na ja leute ist
jetzt erst mal so wir bleiben jetzt
erstmal in wunstorf wirklich ich dachte
mir ich fahre extra aus köln los um nach
berlin zu fahren da bleibe ich doch
nicht zwei stunden in wulsdorf stehen so
aber jetzt passt mal auf es geht ja noch
weiter
das ist ja noch nicht das ende der
geschichte so 14.30 bestehenden wunstorf
15.30 16.30 17.30 und dann kommt
plötzlich jemand auf die idee uns wasser
zu verteilen dankeschön ich wäre schon
fast verdurstet was ist das für ein
service ich erwarte dass bei der bvg
oder bei der kvb aber doch nicht bei der
deutschen bahn
na ja und dann haben wir alle unser
wasser bekommen und um 18.30 gab es dann
für jeden einen kleinen maßregel einen
kleinen masri zum glück hatte die frau
neben mir diabetes und konnte mir ihren
maßregel geben also nicht zum glück weil
neues der scheiße dass sie diabetes hat
aber für mich war es halt glück und das
hat mir dann auch ein bisschen so den
arsch recht hunger hatte und um 19 uhr
hatte ich dann so einen großen hunger
dass ich dann halt nach hinten ins
bistro gegangen bin und mir was zu essen
kaufen wollte und nicht schon deshalb
passten nichts mehr gab weil die leute
halt die ganze zeit gegessen haben ich
meine wie viel kann man essen dass da
schon fast nichts mehr ist leute hat man
auch so viel zu essen und dann wollte
sie halt meine bankkarte nicht annehmen
also ich bin da dann halt hin und habe
gesagt ja ich hätte so gerne
ofenkartoffeln und sie hat gesagt ja das
macht ihn so viel geld noch nicht so
nehmen sie eine bankkarte sie sohn ein
indem du kreditkarten aber meine
kreditkarte hatte ich gerade nicht mit
dabei weil warum soll ich sie dabei
haben und dann als ob sie mir nicht
glaubt dass auf meiner bankkarte geld
ist zwar geld kann ich halt auch keins
dabei also gab es keine offenheit dafür
für mich ich meine wie behindert
zurückgeblieben ist man dass man mir
dann keine ofenkartoffeln gibt ich bin
noch nicht schuld daran dass ich da
jetzt so lange stehen
die deutsche bahn ist auch nicht schuld
daran ist der sturm aber entschuldigen
ich kann auch eine ofenkartoffel umsonst
kriegen was ist euer problem auf jeden
fall war es dann so 20.30 als uns in so
einer richtig nervigen hohen stimme
gesagt wurde liebe fahrgäste wir bleiben
heute
hier in wunsch so dass er die beamten
sind voll und hannover können wir auch
nicht rein meiner aus so viele züge
stehen bitte die nacht über in wunstorf
ich war so genervt dann habe ich
gegoogelt und hab gesehen dass in der
nähe ist und natürlich okay bis ich mich
lieber bevor ich hier mal schlafen gehe
und dann bin ich zu reden dann ist noch
so eine andere frau mit gekommen die
eigentlich nach tschechien wollte und
dann haben wir ganz viel alkohol gekauft
snacks bisschen bier und so und haben
dann angefangen im zug zu trinken und
ich war um 22 30 war ich schon so
betrunken dass ich irgendwann ja dass
mich das auch einfach nicht mehr gestört
hat was wir gerade dadurch leben das war
gut weil ich nicht wusste ob ich sonst
hat die nacht überlebt hätte muss ich
ehrlich sagen mir das ehrlich gesagt für
die rentner vor leid getan weil ich bin
jung am mein körper ist super ich
funktioniere noch aber so ein alter
rentner ist schon ein bisschen behindert
wenn man dann also schlecht wenn man
dann so ja da so einfach mit dem
rollator sitzt und dann kam gegen 1 uhr
nachts die johanniter das ist so wie das
deutsche rote kreuz die kümmern
sicherheit in notsituationen um menschen
und sie hatten wasser kaffee tee eine
decke für jeden und zu essen
kartoffelsuppe ich mag eine
kartoffelsuppe
aber okay und dann war ich nachts noch
ein bisschen draußen bei den johanniter
leuten das ist ein echt super leute
danke schön dass ihr euch so gut um mich
gekümmert habt das fand ich richtig gut
ja dt hat auch echt lecker geschmeckt
und die decke war auch echt war ein
bisschen ungemütlich auf den sitzen zu
schlafen habe ich dann aber auch
irgendwann geschafft so ein paar stunden
und dann bin ich um 35 wieder aufgewacht
ja und das war echt komisch mehr
aufzuwachen und dann so zwischen leuten
zu sein die dafür nicht kennt so fremde
menschen und dann sind wir um sieben uhr
morgens nach hannover gefahren und ich
dachte mir schon endlich meine gebete
wurden erhört sei wie es endlich weg
alles wurde erledigt pustekuchen wir
waren dann noch in hannover stehen
geblieben und dann hat der schaffner
gesagt er weiß noch nicht wann er
weiterfahren kann wir müssen einfach
warten und dann standen wir da 8 uhr 9
uhr nicht da hat mir schon so wird das
jetzt mein leben sein wenn ich jetzt für
immer in meinem leben einfach in dieser
bahn sitzen ja und um 9 uhr sind dann
auch mittlerweile 24 stunden vergangen
24 stunden
in einer bahnfahrt meine freunde haben
immer wieder gefragt wie es mir so geht
und so ich mache ja wie soll es mir
gehen der scheiße es ist hier einfach
aber ein kumpel hat dann gesagt dass er
mich abholen kann
aus hannover und dann war ich aber auch
noch so schlau und stand ja in hannover
und habe dann einer durchsage gehört
dass ich nach braunschweig weiterfahren
kann
das war dann für die personen bisschen
kürzer damit dem ich nicht so lange
abholen muss und ja dann wenn ich nach
braunschweig gefahren und dann kam die
personen hat mich abgeholt mit dem auto
um 13 uhr und um 16 uhr waren wir dann
bei mir in berlin zu hause und jetzt
nochmal wie ich es euch sagen würde ich
war einfach zu dumm um zu checken das
und sturm auf dem weg ist die deutsche
bahn kann nichts dafür dass wir so lange
gebraucht haben xavier kann auch nichts
dafür dass der jetzt dadurch gerät ist
ich kann aber auch nichts dafür das ist
jetzt nicht gecheckt haben in sachen
passieren einfach das ist so und da kann
man einfach daraus lernen dass man in
zukunft vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
darauf achtet auf die wetterbedingungen
besonders wenn man den flex ticket hat
und immer fahren kann wenn man möchte
und keine feste zeit hat ein punkt hat
mich aber wirklich gestört da sie nach
so vielen stunden im bistro nichts zu
essen bekommen habt nur weil ich meine
kreditkarte nicht dabei hatte das war
ziemlich hart weil ich zu dem zeitpunkt
wirklich zwei maßregel magen hatte und
nicht mehr und im bistro essen da war
man es aber nicht bekommen hat also da
stand ich wirklich von dieser frauen
dachte mir was ich habe mir aber auch
nicht getraut irgendwas zu sagen so von
wegen
gib mir jetzt mal bitte was zu essen ich
sterbe fast vor hunger und noch mal
wirklich ganz fett ist danke an diese
leute von johanniter die uns decken
verteilt haben und suppen und getränke
dass sie das so freiwillig gemacht haben
sie waren seit um 1 in danach da und
sind bis morgens um sieben bis wir weg
gefahren sind standen sie da und haben
alles verteilt und es hätte wenn wir
noch länger da geblieben wären um 8 uhr
hättest auch noch frühstück gegeben das
heißt sie hätten dann noch länger
gestanden und das sind alles
ehrenamtliche helfer was ich einfach nur
super fand also dass es solche leute
gibt das hält eigentlich glaube ich um
die ganze gesellschaft zusammen dass es
menschen gibt die halt wirklich dinge
tun nicht aus geld aus macht aus
irgendwas sondern einfach nur um zu
helfen und diese hilfe hat mir eine
decke war wirklich meine der türken war
mathe war meine rettung ein bisschen
kartoffelsuppe fand ich auch super danke
ich werde nie wieder nie wieder werde
ich über eine stunde verspätung oder so
mich aufregen 31 stunden von köln nach
berlin
ich wünsche euch einen schönen tag ich
hoffe euch hat diese story tagen
gefallen ich hoffe ihr wart nicht so
genervt von dieser anderen art
ich fand es ganz lustig macht mir spaß
so mal so dass total übertrieben ist ja
so behände hat ich weiß behindert sagt
man nicht die hat so oft in diesem video
gesagt diese gut ist dort handle wie das
video gemacht hat ihr habt einfach
wirklich ein fehler nach dem anderen
gemacht das ist das war nicht die schuld
von gucci store was was sie da erzählt
hatte so eine dumme geschichte ganz kurz
um zu erklären die freude an der schule
die hat er irgendwie kaputt gemacht und
sind sie zum laden zurück gegangen und
wollten sie umtauschen und die wollten
das aber nicht einfach so machen weil
die gesehen haben dass das eigentlich
selbst verschulden ist und ich bete oder
so selbst verschwunden war
die das nur irgendwie so ne hier euren
koffern ist das kaputt gegangen und dann
kann man war das beste dann wollten sie
diese schule nehmen und das zur
qualitätsprüfung italien schicken dann
hatte der freund aber die schuhe an wer
zieht denn die schuhe an die er
zurückgeben möchte oder umtauschen will
dann ziehst du andere schuhe an
du gehst du nicht mit dem kaputten waren
noch mal raus um sowie noch kaputt zu
machen oder ich weiß es nicht es war
naja bis dann und und videos und
abonnieren und bis dann tschüssi copski
zschau